i don't know what's happening with you i
can't tell my kids i'm scared they have
enough problems they don't need to worry
about mom a health scare brings kris
jenner to tears in the new trailer for
the kardashians season two i'm like oh
boy and a sneak peek chris in a hospital
bed appearing as if she's about to go
into a procedure her boyfriend corey
gamble gives her a kiss before we see
the matriarch back on screen overtaken
with emotion they have enough problems
they don't need to worry about mom the
episodes are more a little bit
documentary style and i think that you
have a real insight into what's really
happening behind the scenes while the
details about chris's health situation
are currently unclear
one thing is for sure this is a family
that always rallies to support each
other in good times and bad we saw that
firsthand earlier this month when
courtney's husband travis barker found
himself in a life-threatening situation
rushed to the hospital for pancreatitis
a situation that a store sells et only
brought travis closer to his wife
i've never met
a better human in my life thankfully
travis has since been discharged and
according to our source he quote has
been trying to take it easy and rest so
that he can get back to his best healthy
self soon we're told the entire
kardashian jenner family was really
scared after finding out his diagnosis
we love travis but quote everyone is
glad that travis is on the mend now
okay season two here we come
let's go now back to season two of the
kardashians i don't know what's
happening with you on top of chris's
health scare the trailer also teases
some lighter moments including kylie
giving birth to her and travis scott's
second child kylie
baby number two
congratulations thank you courtney
picking a dress for her wedding to
travis and this stammy moment between
kim and pete davidson
yeah do you want to shower with me
really quick
well we'll have to wait to see more of
that when season 2 of the kardashians
premieres september 22nd on hulu
we did speak with kim about her romance
with pete back in april and the beauty
mogul dished on her favorite thing about
the comedian he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
that's my favorite thing
what about the goal is finding someone
to do nothing with it's the best because
you don't do everything with totally but
it's crazy to be distracted with people
you can be with anyone
distracted but you can't be with anyone
and do nothing
[Music]
you